[Music]
of all the jungle cruises you could take
in the amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest
but also the most thrilling heads up
coming through look out
marauders
natives
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the backside of water
stays wonder of the world
anjana frankie mr nila please don't call
me that i'm going to keep your engine i
got my money then you'll get it back
frank gives me money
[Music]
miss milo frank goes me money not a good
time my brother and i are looking
i gotta be honest it's not a fun
vacation
are you gonna beg me to turn back
ten thousand to bring you there live
dead it's fifteen thousand
why should i pay more debt
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady here we go
i got you
it's impossible
fail the gun is in my hand sorry
i'll make it next time you almost got me
didn't you boy
we had a lot of fun today i could take
her again next week go
home safer
[Music]
[Music]
shadow
[Music]
what do you want you're coming with us
kid
get the girl it's not me you need to be
scared of little girl
but the man standing next to you now i
don't know who he is
but i know who he's not should i tell
[Applause]
her
he's gonna come for me now
you're gonna see what i see
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
delivery i gave you the special since
you're the only madrigal kid with no
gift
i call it the not special special since
uh you have no gift uh thanks
gift or no gift i am just as special as
the rest of my family
who wants more pink all right guys where
do i drop the wagon maybe your gift is
being in denial
ugh
[Music]
this is not a cure the only way we're
gonna make progress
is cutting edge avant-garde treatment
i've got this condition it makes me snap
like directs
just tiny bit more
intense i've upped the voltage
but there's only so much that the human
body can take
hello this is detective vickers it
sounds like your guy was involved in
some pretty sketchy business
i'm gonna find you did this
if you go down that path you are never
ever going to get better
deal with her you spent years being
forced to repress your anger
but now you have seen how powerful you
can be when you embrace
your age oh seriously you're gonna make
me go through the whole
face dumping bone breaking making a mess
routine
okay fine
you're gonna get somebody killed i'm
trying to help you uh-huh how's that
going for you
what is it about gross old men always
underestimating women
are you really that stupid you know what
i think i am
exactly that stupid
[Music]
[Applause]
i went to confess my sins
now you might think this is a bit of an
excessive reaction
as you can see we're already having a
pretty cramp ass day
sweet lord jesus brought me to the city
of angels
for a purpose yeah
they do grow pretty in texas
you can always work for me you know
working at the club aka selling a bunch
of drugs to la's horniest
crackheads
i should have listened to you all the
money and all his [ __ ] drugs are gone
okay
find a way to get me that 20 grand back
[Music]
i know your plates i know your friends
this is a scary drug dealer
that i'm trying to make a good
impression with now i need your help
more than ever
show me that life
you're a [ __ ] badass
[Music]
who are you supposed to tell people we
came to hollywood to start a comment
i haven't seen you before well look at
god just working his ways
do you know where to get waxed around
here
[Music]
always did have flavor for danger
i hate them should i
kill them
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not
so what do i know about you
this is it soon everyone will know my
name dresses
by ella life outside this basement
starts right now
do you want to go to that ball yes i was
just crying and singing about it like
two minutes ago
[Music]
[Music]
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now behold the transformation ray
awesome but this is safe though let's
find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up
johnny
[Music]
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad you're human dread oh no
i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me
i've literally never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this there
is a place
deep in the amazon only there can the
transformations be reversed
time to go
wow flying his monster is so much better
right
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious
it's wondrous it's
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever seriously
everybody relax just enjoy the view
ah please being a human is the worst
can't relax mosquitoes
hotel transylvania transfer mania boy
that was fun
the only place to experience transfer
mania is in a movie theater october 1st
[Music]
when i was a kid guys like me were
brought up to follow coach
hey circle
[Music]
what'd you say what
antonio soprano
i wonder if i can talk to you along for
a moment mr soprano
on the basis of the sanford binet he's
high iq
you can't prove it by me he's got a d
plus average
well he doesn't apply himself but he is
smart
the results tell us he's a leader
ankle dick growing up with the family
takes a toll maybe an ambassador
i want to go to college i can't get
caught with [ __ ] like this
you take the speakers right at the same
time you say to yourself
is the last time i'm ever gonna steal
something it's that simple
let me go talk to him he only listens to
dickie
i gotta do something about dickie
madasani
maybe some of the things you do
aren't god's favorite
only by example we'll make the right
decision this kid's got what it takes
as far as your nephew goes
i'm listening stay out of his life
got yourself
[Music]
lord raiden
i offer an end to the bloodshed a final
tournament that will determine not just
the future of our realm
but the others as well
a tournament like a what karate
tournament
it's a whole thing i'll explain later
greetings warriors of earth realm
welcome to the final mortal kombat
never mind that sums it up
i can't breathe don't be such a baby
it's just a kick in the nuts
finish him
fatality mortal combat legends battle of
the realms
yeah i forgot i brought my girlfriend
and
whoa she is pretty good with a rifle
on digital in blu-ray
you may not believe it but there is
magic all around us
[Music]
there are times it can be hard to find
did you bring your garbage to school
but sometimes stuff the magic
finds us look at you uncle casey
so cute i'm so red how big is he gonna
get
that depends doesn't it unless on how
much you love him
i wish you were big and strong and the
world could nervous
[Music]
we're gonna be late for school
[Music]
why don't we get you on the scale here
bud i'm just gonna write
heavy what if you found someone who made
you feel like you could do anything
[Music]
clickers
[Music]
well you don't see that every day maybe
it's time to feed him
[Music]
hey you kids it's dinner time
why does nobody come in through the
front door dearest mother and father we
will not be attending this evening's
ritual mastication what
they're both growing up so fast they
wouldn't be caught dead with their
parents
wait a minute what i've got a dish
it's tedious it's monstrous
it's the old adam's camper
time for some family bonding what huh we
are going
on a road trip this is cruel even for
you
this trip will bring the atoms closer
than ever before
let's make some memories
[Music]
it's just us and the wonderful sound of
silence
[Music]
now that's great
[Music]
it's good to see you my big whisker
cousin i still don't understand the word
that guy say
where's kitty he and it hit the catnip
pretty hard last night
all right guys the quadratic formula
let the fun begin who could tell me how
the formula begins
x equals
[Applause]
no no no this isn't happening
what is that oh snap all right
settle down little goblins wow
[Music]
gotta get home
[Music]
then
yes no
[Music]
dinner's
god is great god is good let us thank
him for our food
by his hands we all are fed
marcus the entire town has just dropped
dead
dr lauren stone why am i here
they say if it's out of this world you
will find it
it's a meteorite it appears to have just
hit and dissolved into the soil
whatever it is it's highly toxic and you
just don't want to breathe it
[Music]
he's healing
what
how is this even possible
it's a formation of a new life form
within the human body what the hell does
that mean
aliens general oh boy
we need to be able to stop it we need
answers this wasn't
an accident we were targeted
it wants to talk to you they're all
facing north
it's the plant
[Music]
welcome to earth
[Music]
get him out of my head
you cannot stop us
hey lola checking in from idaho i'll
call you again from twin falls okay
i miss you hug joseph for me
hey you all right yeah i'm all right see
that's what you need to do what mom
tells you to do walk against the trap
what you're 15 all right i'm 45 you
think i don't know what the hell i'm
doing out here yeah no i don't
that's why i'm with you
[Music]
my name is joe bell i'm on a walk for
change
i'm walking across america to speak out
against bullying
i'm getting picked on by these guys at
school why is that i'm just i'm
different i'm just
that's not an answer jade no i cause i'm
gay
we're gonna let nature take its course
all right it'll all be fine it'll work
itself out yeah what
it's not gonna work itself out my son is
15 years old
took his own life because he was bullied
this is your fault you knew he was
suffering i mean what did you
there's a lot of things i've learned out
here nobody but me for company
some of it's been hard to come to know
stop just be careful all right lola
that's all don't ever let them steal
your choice i still feel jaden's
presence
i thought being out in the wild would
help you be a man what does that mean to
you be a man
i was afraid for you all right we were
all afraid for you
knew before he died that you loved him
and accepts them that's what matters
isn't it i never let him know it was
okay i got to live with that
i saw your eyes behind your head i don't
think i keep going
i just want to come home if you're
walking for dave and you let jaden let
you know when it's time to come out
maybe if you walk long enough and far
enough you can find me again
i failed my son and it's too late for me
to make things right with him
if there's just one thing you remember
today you make it this
hold on to the ones you love and you
love them for who they are because you
may not get that chance again
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people are wondering what
happened last night with you and the boy
if you touch me you will burn
eric your embassy has sent some people
to take you back to america
[Music]
just get in the car
[Music]
you cannot reach a city you do agree
with me right you've seen what he's done
here
i saw it with my own eyes you're lucky
to be alive
sometimes i just get these visions i see
things well like they're different
worlds right i can walk around i can
touch things i can feel things i feel
the wind i feel the heat
i'm not saying he's a bad person
i don't care what he is we need to get
him under control
get out of there as quickly as you can
[Music]
[Music]
i think something happened that nobody
quite understands yet
[Music]
throughout my life the ten rings
gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family you are your
mother
and whether you like it or not you are
also your father
i told my men they wouldn't be able to
kill you if they tried
glenn i was right
here's just a criminal who murders
people
start a new life
but i could never escape his shadow
my son you can't run from your past
is this what you wanted
uh you got this
thank you
i want everyone to answer this question
all right i'll give you a second to
think about it
now raise your hand if you think you're
a lucky person
just ramon okay raise your hand if you
think you're unlucky
got it okay and put your hands down what
about you mr corman
was that you didn't raise your hand me
uh
no i i mean i feel like a lucky person
[Music]
i'm having anxiety or panic or something
both
yeah what's the difference i'm gonna
need a sub for today what's bothering
you
everything it just feels like i blew the
whole thing like i
suck as a person you're not entitled to
a perfect partner or a perfect life
i didn't leave you because you became a
teacher i left because i thought i was
doing what i love with the man i love
to see me through how was your weekend
it was great man there guys walk away
all right good morning happy monday
everything is a complete disaster you
have the privilege of expecting
everything to just work out
now that you're faced with some
adversity
it could feel like the end of the world
you want to stop feeling like you're
feeling
what about this weighted blanket it
costs 250 we can make our own version
you can't
make your own version
[Music]
you feeling less anxious no i'm really
not
i can't stop thinking about all the
things you should have done and why you
didn't do
i know i can be negative sometimes it's
not how i want to be
nothing is perfect i don't know why
that's so hard for you to see
the question is what do you do now
when your name is justin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she was called mother earth
we plundered everything she offered
none of us should have come back
where i'm from all reproductive
technology efforts failed for both men
and women
i want to prove that we can procreate
here on earth
you came to earth on the first mission
we waited so long
it's imperative that we give future
generations the chance of civilization
and bring our people home
for
[Music]
who are they survivors monks
we called them
i saw a child
we can repopulate our planet
there are children they won't be by the
time our people arrive
keep an eye on her my daughter
where is she i want to help you
let's go
are you still with us blake
our predecessors failed us in so many
ways
are they coming
let's get out of here trust me
foreign
[Music]
you